you know i think that we're exactly
where we were
uh last year when i made comments after
the draft and and throughout the season
you know i i don't feel like any of
that's changed
uh even my comments directly after the
last game there was some and we talked
about on this show yeah some
you know some people who thought you
know who made assumptions uh based on
what i said
um nothing's really changed you know my
my future
uh is is really a lot of it's out of my
control um you know that's why i
mentioned you know using words like a
phrase like beautiful mystery like
because it is uh it is quite uh
uncertain
uh which directions things are going to
go um all i can do is play my best and i
feel like last year i did do that and
may have thrown a wrench into some
timelines that may have been thought
about or desired
that's aaron rodgers from the pat mcafee
show today he still is upset that people
made assumptions based upon the things
he said
back in january after the buccaneers
lost or the buccaneers beat the packers
in the nfc championship game people made
reasonable assumptions he's the one
that dropped the
brown smelly thing into the punch bowl
and made us all say what in the hell is
aaron rodgers talking about
and so don't don't just please please i
i got a ton of respect for aaron rodgers
as a player i got a ton of respect for
him as a host of jeopardy and i think
he's going to be great i think he's
incredibly brilliant i don't like it
when he makes statements that invite
assumptions invite analysis invite
comment and then he gets pissed off when
we do our job shireen that bugs me more
than anything that he does it's the only
thing that he does that bugs me but it
bugs the hell out of me
yeah and he does it quite often mike and
he did it again today but uh we'll see
what aaron rodgers future is in green
bay this does remind me a lot of the the
far rogers years just simply because
aaron rodgers was 21 when he was drafted
to the packers and farv was 35 and
rogers was 36 when the packers drafted
21 year old jordan love the question is
how long is aaron rodgers going to
remain in green bay and it's still a
question and i agree with him he doesn't
i get what he's coming from he doesn't
control his future but at the same time
the packers have a big decision to make
on what they're going to do with aaron
rodgers but the timeline was changed
i've said that all along if he doesn't
have the mvp season he had this year i
think he's gone from the packers in 2021
he's playing for somebody else and all
these dominoes were seeing fallen they
would have been completely different
based on aaron rodgers going somewhere
else
hey sheree one of the reasons i think he
had an mvp season in 2020 is because
mark murphy the ceo of the team who
knows how to pull his strings and press
his buttons got him into the sweet spot
of pissed off just in the right spot
where he was not so upset that he
started turning over apple carts but
that he was upset enough that he went
out and had an mvp season and they're
going to try to do it again this year
they're trying to keep him in that sweet
spot just pissed off enough that he goes
out and he has another mvp season and i
remember when they drafted jordan love
last year i thought you know if they
play this right they will piss him off
well enough that he will have great
seasons until either he's ready to talk
his way out of town or the packers are
ready to push him on an iceberg and it
could be i talked about this earlier
today he could find a way to thread this
needle where jeopardy loves him so much
they want him to be the permanent host
he convinces them to wait for one more
football season he plays one more year
and then he says to mark murphy stick
this in your trophy case and he goes and
he takes over jeopardy so i i think if
nothing else and this is one thing that
i think i do have in common with aaron
rodgers and one of the reasons i think
he doesn't like me is because we have a
lot in common i know how he thinks and
i'm able to better understand the
messages he's trying to send i believe
that he desperately is looking for a way
to control his exit from green bay in a
way that doesn't make him a pariah and
there's one way to stick it to the
packers and walk away and not piss off
the packers fans and that is to trade in
number 12 for a suit
and a game show set and take over
jeopardy for the next 40 years i i think
that is the dream scenario for aaron
rodgers that he would never say out loud
and when someone does he's going to say
no that's really not what i'm thinking
well he said today he'd love to be the
permanent host of jeopardy and
i think he'd love to do it after having
another mvp season maybe winning a super
bowl and then saying see you later mark
murphy see you later brian goody koontz
see you later packers um i'm leaving on
my own terms you're not going to push me
out when you're ready to let me go and
and i'm sure he would love that outcome
if he could pull it off shereen
yeah no question mike and and it would
be great to see him walk off into the
sunset too few quarterbacks do that we
saw with peyton manning we saw with john
elway but too few have done that it
would be terrific to see him win a super
bowl and win another mvp award that
would be number four and then just say
i'm out of here it's been fun it's been
real i'm gonna go take my 10 million a
year for the next x number of years to
go host jeopardy and i think he'd be
really good at that he's he prepares
apparently prepared for jeopardy the
same way he prepares for his on the
field play we know that's worked for him
through the year so
it's going to be fun to see him on
jeopardy how he does starting today and
then we'll see what his future is in
green bay mike but i don't think it's
long for green bay i see him
playing one more year maybe two but i
don't even know if that's the case to me
the mvp if he gets another mvp award
this year that really complicates what
the packers want to do and maybe changes
their timeline yet again but then rogers
can as you said say goodbye i'm out of
here
i think he wants to dictate the timeline
and that's his motivation at this point
and that would be the best possible exit
for him and it would be a one-of-a-kind
exit walking away from football at the
height of his game telling the packers
see you later have fun with jordan love
and exiting completely out of football
staying in media taking over jeopardy
and making a crapload of money to work
one day a week good work if you can
ultimately get it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports